على خيبة الأمل الكبيرة اليوم
أعلم أن هناك الملايين
[موسيقى]
أعلم أن السبب الرئيسي للحزن
انتظار أكبر بكثير للبلد
هي مشاكل
[موسيقى]
الآن
لنفسك ولأطفالنا
لمتقاعدينا ، أمهاتنا
تاجر مزارع لآبائنا
لإخواننا
دعم لمواصلة النضال من أجل الديمقراطية
يعطي
[موسيقى]
أيها الأطفال
لا تحزنوا أيها الشباب الغالي.
لا تكن أبدا غير سعيد
السيدات لا تكن عصبيا
أيها السادة ، استمروا في المشي ورأسك مرفوعة.
دعونا نفعل أشياء كثيرة وعظيمة في وقت قصير
الشيء الذي يمكن أن ينجح ، سننجح مرة أخرى
في نفس الوقت حزبنا كثيف
على الفور من يوم غد الانتخابات المحلية
بدأ العمل فيها
[موسيقى]
ألف مبروك للسيد رجب طيب أردوغان
أعتقد أن قرار أمتنا
خير لأمتنا وبلدنا
أمتنا تصلي من أجلنا
وفقًا لمسؤوليتها
أساء لأي شخص غاضب غاضب غاضب
لم نعد نتحدث عن فترة الانتخابات
تنحي الحجج والمشاجرات جانبا.
ترك أهدافنا الوطنية وطنية
حول أحلامنا